it was tough to believe we live in a
country where you could be fired from
your job for having the wrong thoughts
or reading unapproved political
materials but unfortunately that is the
country we're becoming it happened to
Carolyn she used to work for a small
games company called limited run games
then the mob found out that she followed
certain forbidden Twitter accounts
including Libs of tick tock now this mob
and this is usually the case was led by
a single activist on Twitter along with
a small Message Board called reset era
as a result of this mob action Carolyn
was fired and we want to understand
exactly why and what happened Carolyn
joins us today here thank you so much
for coming on do we oversimplify that so
you followed the wrong people on Twitter
and lost your job for it
um to me I think that's kind of the this
what sums it up
um the funny thing about it is it's
accounts that I've I follow accounts of
every political
um affiliation and I'm the type of
person who likes to see from every
direction and so I follow a very a
variety of accounts so
the
when they called you in does it fire you
did they say we we believe you've been
reading the wrong things like how how
did they phrase it
no no no it was more of uh the the
public the uh the publicity that was
getting it
um that that was the main thing they
they had no qualms with who I followed
or anything like that
but you lost your job as a result of it
yes
yes well I mean I don't I mean that's
not supposed to happen in a free country
with a First Amendment right
I would hope not
yeah but it did
um you're you're so good humored about
it I mean I'm like outraged on your
behalf I hope that the lesson you take
is you go follow even more forbidden
Twitter accounts and that you make more
money in an even better job we are
rooting for you Carolyn thank you very
much
thank you so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight